noch sinken die infektionszahlen jeden
tag aber die vorweihnachtliche
entspannung dürfte trügerisch sein die
neue omikron variante kommt und soll
noch ansteckender sein das robert koch
institut stuft die gefahr als sehr hoch
für ungeimpfte ein hoch für zwei mal
geimpft und moderat für drei mal geimpft
am nachmittag will kanzler scholz mit
den länderchefs virtuell beraten wie
vorbereiten auf diese drohende fünfte
welle und vor allem wie schnell müssen
neue einschränkungen kommen am besten
sofort sagt der hamburger bürgermeister
es könne nur eine strategie geben
so stark und so umfassend wie es möglich
ist und bis auf weiteres weitere
kontakte einzuschränken damit die
infektions dynamik gebremst wird ein
beschlussentwurf aus dem kanzleramt
dringt vorab durch darin steht was
bundesweit kommen könnte spätestens ab
dem 28 dezember kontakt beschränkungen
auch für geimpfte und genesene treffen
dann nur noch mit maximal zehn personen
spätestens dann würden auch clubs und
diskotheken geschlossen und
großveranstaltungen dürften nur noch
ohne zuschauer stattfinden wie gesagt
bisher nur ein entwurf und über das
timing gibt es streit
mach doch ein bisschen unsicherheit wenn
einerseits gesagt wird auch vom
bundesgesundheitsminister also
weihnachten ist alles okay silvester
geht aber quasi die welt unter ich denke
wir müssen heute einfach klarheit
schaffen planungssicherheit gibt und den
menschen auch vertrauen geben mancher in
der neuen ampel koalition fordert
härtere maßnahmen gar einen lock down ab
januar wenn es sich so ausbreiten sollte
wie in großbritannien dänemark
niederlande
dann werden wir nicht normale geschäfte
offen lassen können sondern wir werden
allenfalls apotheken lebensmittelhandel
für den täglichen bedarf offen halten
könnt nicht mit uns sagt die fdp die in
dieser frage am stärksten unter druck
gerät die fdp weiß aber dass viele
menschen in unserem land sich vor einem
neuerlichen lockdown fürchten pauschale
schließungen von
schulen oder des handels
sollten immer nur die ultima ratio
bleiben am abend wieder demonstrationen
gegen die korona politik vielerorts in
deutschland wie hier in mannheim mit
etwa 800 teilnehmern wo es zum teil auch
in gewalt eskalierte und 13
einsatzkräfte verletzt wurden mehrere
hundert demonstranten auch im
sächsischen bautzen und 10.000 waren es
am abend in rostock
ja und um 16 uhr kommen dann heute bund
und länder zur digitalen sitzung
zusammen das ziel haben wir gehört die
omikron welle in schach zu halten
darüber spreche ich jetzt mit dem
vorstandsvorsitzenden der deutschen
krankenhausgesellschaft gerald gaß
schönen guten tag
schönen guten tag nach berlin
das erfordert das haben wir gerade
gehört jetzt sofortige kontakt
beschränkungen nicht erst nach
weihnachten
inwieweit würde das denn den
krankenhäusern hessen
alles was jetzt getan werden kann um
kontakte zu beschränken ist wichtig wir
müssen tatsächlich präventiv vorgehen es
ist ja im moment noch die situation dass
die instanzen sinken aber die große
sorge und die berechtigte sorge ist dass
sich das sehr schnell ändern kann und
deswegen präventiv jetzt schon kontakte
zu beschränken um die ausbreitung des
virus zu vermeiden ist auf jeden fall
richtig das heißt wie weit sind denn die
häuser die kliniken tatsächlich von der
überlastung entfernt
wir befinden uns kurz hinter dem
scheitelpunkt der flutwelle wir hatten
ja fast 5000 patienten patienten auf den
intensivstationen
die zahl ist leicht gesunken aber noch
weit über 4000 und wir gehen davon aus
dass wir nur noch wenig absinken werden
bevor dann die fünfte welle auf uns
trifft die ja möglicherweise noch
deutlich größer sein soll und dann
beginnt eben wieder der kampf um die
priorisierung und darum auch die anderen
patientinnen und patienten möglichst zu
versorgen das heißt konkret
da kann es dann passieren dass leute
nicht mehr versorgt werden oder wie man
habe ich das zu verstehen
das bedeutet dass wir wieder viele
menschen auf die wartelisten setzen
müssen dass wir priorisieren müssen das
hier entscheiden müssen vor ort wer
kommt zunächst dran aber
selbstverständlich werden wir alles in
unserer macht stehende tun den
patientinnen patienten die dringend und
schnell hilfe benötigen diese auch
zukommen zu lassen ich bin
zuversichtlich dass uns das auch in den
kommenden wochen gelingt aber es hängt
davon ab dass wir diese fünfte welle
nicht zu groß werden lassen und deswegen
sind diese maßnahmen richtig und ich
appelliere sehr an die bevölkerung hier
mitzumachen das heißt mit einer
sogenannten triage das erste wirklich
gucken müssen wen können wir jetzt
sozusagen behandeln und wen nicht damit
rechnen sie jetzt noch nicht
im moment rechnen wir nicht damit weil
wir wirklich die berechtigte hoffnung
haben dass es uns durch das boostern und
durch die kontakt beschränkungen gelingt
die vielzahl an gleichzeitig
auftretenden fällen möglichst zu
vermeiden und damit ja wirklich diese
befürchtete triage nicht wahr werden zu
lassen wie bereiten sie sich als
krankenhäuser eigentlich auf die
herausforderungen vor die ja jetzt wohl
auf jeden fall kommen werden die frage
ist ja nur wie groß sozusagen die
herausforderung wird also fordern sie
dann hilfe vielleicht von der bundeswehr
an oder wie reagieren sie darauf
selbstverständlich bereiten wir uns vor
wir haben über die ganze pandemie hinweg
immer wieder unsere haus individuellen
pandemiepläne aktualisiert das passiert
jetzt auch eben mit der sorge dass
möglicherweise auch ein teil des
personals zusätzlich noch ausfällt das
ist ja ein problem was möglicherweise
ins haus steht und dann beginnt vor
allen dingen die absprache mit den
umliegenden krankenhäusern zunächst mal
und dann versucht man beispielsweise mit
kooperierenden reha-kliniken sich
zusammenzutun um personal zu akquirieren
selbstverständlich werden urlaube dann
nicht möglich sein und ähnliches und in
einzelfällen kommt es auch vor dass
externes personal
hinzugezogen werden muss vielleicht
sogar von der bundeswehr dann schauen
wir mal aufs personal experten raten ja
jetzt schon dringend zu boostern da
sonst der schutz bei nur zweifach
geimpften oder genesenen zu gering sei
wie ist denn der status der booster
status beim klinikpersonal
die krankenhäuser haben ja sehr früh im
jahr 2020 ihre mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter geimpft das heißt unsere
mitarbeiter waren schon sehr früh
zweimal geimpft und deswegen haben wir
auch sehr früh schon vor einigen wochen
mit dem boostern begonnen und wir können
sagen dass bei uns in den krankenhäusern
doch die große zahl der mitarbeiter auch
wirklich jetzt gebucht hat ist alle
arbeitgeber haben dort klinik interne
impfaktionen durchgeführt und da sind
wir wirklich sehr weit heute also dann
jetzt das treffen von bund und ländern
sie haben schon gesagt man muss
präventiv sozusagen vorsorge treffen was
erwarten sie jetzt konkret von den
beschlüssen heute
es ist ja mehr oder weniger schon
bekannt was beschlossen werden soll da
geht es jetzt um das verbot von
großveranstaltungen oder weiteren
öffentlichen veranstaltungen unmittelbar
nach weihnachten aber es geht eben auch
darum größere private zusammenkünfte ja
zu verbieten beziehungsweise zu
reglementieren und hier wissen wir da
kommt es wirklich auf die mitwirkung der
bevölkerung an und deswegen ist gute
kommunikation wichtig man kann so etwas
nicht durchgehend kontrollieren oder
sanktionieren wir zählen da sehr auf die
eigene einsicht der menschen auch und
das hat in der vergangenheit ja auch gut
funktioniert und deswegen noch mal mein
appell hier mitzumachen sagt wäre als
gast von der deutschen
krankenhausgesellschaft vielen dank für
das gespräch
[Musik]